there's a big story right now where uh
Texas has begun arresting illegal
immigrants I love this story in defiance
of uhring them today oh yeah yeah yeah
and uh I'm telling you like we we grain
of sand being added to the Heap at some
point the federal government either has
to admit it's been defeated look I'll
put it this way by Texas which is kind
of perfect well that's it the dam has
broken it it the dam is broken okay we
we are not necessarily looking at Fort
Sumpter although I wasn't the one who
made this point I can't remember they
made this point um I think it might have
been like Benny Johnson I'm not sure
that uh yeah I think it was Benny he was
saying that the federal you know start
of the first Civil War first Civil War
the federal government is saying this is
our territory the south is saying no
it's not and there's a standoff nobody
really dies but we call that the start
right now in Texas the federal
government is saying uh uh Texas is
breaking the law is breaking federal law
barring them from access to the river
and they have no authority to enforce
border issues and Texas saying we're
going to do it anyway